alors date et lieu de naissance d'alain
souchon casablanca en 44 le 27 mai c'est
bidon
le vrai nom d'alain souchon basse et
c'est alain alain souchon nhât hanh
enfin le nom de ton père est alors alors
son sens on se serre sont donc voilà non
non non en fait non en fait c'est des
histoires un peu compliqué certes quand
il est né à l'époque c'était il est sa
mère était marié avec quelqu'un qui
s'appelait kiena c'est ça mais son vrai
père c'est souchon donc c'était
compliqué de s'appeler souchon à
l'époque mais on s'est sauvé ribot c'est
le sujet avec survient une fois alain
souchon at il échoué au bac 4 ou 5 fois
l'offre
non moi à 3 alors 3 quel était le surnom
de la femme d'alain souchon quand il l'a
rencontrée mais c'est toujours le même
c'est bellotte bravo comment s'appelait
deux premiers disques d'alain souchon
qui sont complètement passés inaperçus
alors je suis en bas je suis un vrai nom
s'était les oiseaux non oui non chine
puis chambéry nantes je sais plus je
suis un voyageur un voyageur ma maison
est ailleurs voilà et un coin de
solitude de sucre était bien le fils de
la soochow est oui oui pourtant il a
fait souche en deuxième langue
c'est comme une chance sinon barbara qui
ressemble à bout d'istres et et d'un
côté voulzy et yannick noah pour quel
chanteur alain souchon at il compose et
l'amour 1830 qu'il finira par chanter
lui même d'ailleurs
ouais frédéric françois bien oui mais
c'est vrai qu'en soit le cabinet date la
première collaboration souchon voulzy
j'aurais dû me friser les cheveux ce
soir on était la première collaboration
date de 73 n'ont ainsi pas ce que
c'était j'ai dix ans ils sortiront 73 on
va 73 valeureux train de les revendre
des 173
quel est le premier succès d'alain
souchon mais j'ai dix ans bon allez chez
dix ans en première partie de ghinzu
champ at il fait son premier olympia le
luron non voulzy non jean jacques debout
oui pour quel film de françois truffaut
alain souchon a dit les 8 bravo bon quel
film alain souchon at il débuté sa
carrière de comédien si je vous aime de
claude berri bravo et 2 par des deux
navigateurs qui s'y connait un
quelle chanson d'alain souchon a été
victoire de la musique de la chanson en
1990 chez moi le sentimental non larbi
chouikha
on a mûri
chatou